at 95 queen elizabeth ii is already the
longest-serving monarch in british
history
the platinum jubilee marks the sudden
death of her father king george vi in
1952 when she acceded to the throne
she's reigned for 70 years
in a ceremony dating from the time of
richard ii
celebrations will be in the summer like
previous anniversaries
the silver jubilee in 1977
25 years on the throne
gold marking 50 years
in 2002
and the diamond her 16th in 2012.
queen elizabeth approaches this jubilee
without her husband of 73 years prince
philip the duke of edinburgh he died
last april she once described him as her
strength and stay
the queen cut a solitary figure in grief
there are other strains on her prince
harry and his wife megan breaking away
from the royal family and moving to the
united states among attacks they've made
on the royal family is a racist
allegation against one of them who isn't
named and the queen has stripped her
second son prince andrew of military
titles he faces a sexual abuse lawsuit
in the united states which he's
contesting
there have been serious problems
on the other hand it's worth remembering
this is a unique commemoration and
celebrating it over four days will i
think be a matter for enormous rejoicing
for the british public
britain's unrivaled pomp and ceremony
will be on show in june trying to lift a
post-pandemic national mood the queen
has chosen her birthday tradition of
trooping the color to begin celebrations
and trooping the color here in the mile
will mark the start of a four day public
holiday including street parties
initiatives such as a mass planting of
trees all over the country then 1
500 beacons will be ablaze all over the
uk
and in commonwealth capitals overseas
a party in the palace will follow which
will include a concert and then the
platinum pageant a massive event here in
the capital
it's hard to find anyone with a bad word
for the queen
i couldn't praise her enough what a
great lady she's cool i like her she's
such a character of resilience strength
and inspiration the last bastion when it
comes to
what monarchy used to represent in this
country
there's never been a platinum jubilee in
the uk with a backdrop though of
controversy and scandal it does beg the
question
without the queen would there be such
support for the monarchy in the uk
andrew simmons al jazeera london